there's an organism that changed the
world
it caused both the first mass extinction
in earth's history and also paved the
way for complex life how by sending the
first free oxygen molecules into our
atmosphere and they did all this as
single celled life-forms
they're cyanobacteria and the story of
these simple organisms that don't even
have nuclei or any other organelles is a
pivotal chapter in the story of life on
Earth Earth's atmosphere wasn't always
the oxygen-rich mixture we breathe today
three and a half billion years ago the
atmosphere was mostly nitrogen carbon
dioxide and methane almost all oxygen
was locked up in molecules like water
not floating around in the air the
oceans were populated by anaerobic
microbes those are simple unicellular
life forms that thrive without oxygen
and get energy by scavenging what
molecules they find but somewhere
between 2.5 and 3.5 billion years ago
one of these microbial species probably
floating on the surface of the ocean
evolved a new ability photosynthesis
structures in their cell membrane could
harness the energy from sunlight to turn
carbon dioxide and water into oxygen gas
and sugars which they could use for
energy those organisms were the
ancestors of what we now call
cyanobacteria their bluish color comes
from the blue-green pigments that
capture the sunlight they need
photosynthesis gave those ancient
bacteria a huge advantage over other
species they could now produce their own
energy from an almost endless supply of
raw ingredients so their populations
exploded and they started polluting the
atmosphere with a new waste product
oxygen at first the trickle of extra
oxygen was soaked up by chemical
reactions with iron ore decomposing
cells but after a few hundred million
years the cyanobacteria were producing
oxygen faster than it could be absorbed
and the gas started building up in the
atmosphere that was a big problem for
the rest of Earth's inhabitants
oxygen-rich air was actually toxic to
them the result about two and a half
billion years ago was a mass extinction
of virtually all life on Earth which
barely spared the cyanobacteria
geologists call this the great
oxygenation event
or even the oxygen catastrophe that
wasn't the only problem
methane had been acting as a potent
greenhouse gas that kept the earth warm
but now the extra oxygen reacted with
methane to form carbon dioxide and water
which don't trap as much heat
the thinner atmospheric blanket caused
Earth's first and possibly longest ice
age the huronian glaciation the planet
was basically one giant snowball for
several hundred million years eventually
life adjusted aerobic organisms which
can use oxygen for energy started
sopping up some of the excess gas in the
atmosphere the oxygen concentration rose
and fell until eventually it reached the
approximate 21 percent we have today and
being able to use the chemical energy
and oxygen gave organisms the boost they
needed to diversify and evolve more
complex forms cyanobacteria had a part
to play in that story to hundreds of
millions of years ago some other
prehistoric microbe swallowed a
cyanobacterium hole in a process called
endosymbiosis in doing so that microbe
acquired its own internal photosynthesis
Factory this was the ancestor of plant
cells and cyanobacteria became
chloroplasts the organelles that carry
out photosynthesis today cyanobacteria
are still around in almost every
environment on Earth oceans fresh water
soil antarctic rocks sloths fur they
still pump oxygen into the atmosphere
and they also pull nitrogen out to
fertilize the plants they helped create
we wouldn't recognize life on earth
without them but also thanks to them we
almost didn't have life on Earth at all